- [Voiceover] You can
be pursuing a profession
because your parents
say it's the best thing.
You can be pursuing a profession
because you think you'll
make a lot of money.
You can be pursuing a profession
because you think you're going
to get a lot of attention.
None of that will do you any good
if you are not being honest with yourself.
Oprah Winfrey.
Most people waste their lives
living someone else's dream.
They imprison themselves by accepting
the results of other people's thinking.
They allow the opinions of others
to crush their own inner voice.
You might have been beaten down so often
that now you stomp out your own dreams
before they even have a chance to blossom.
You have become your own little man.
It's time to rediscover yourself.
The ancient Greeks had a proverb,
Gnothi Seauton, know thyself.
It was used as a warning
to pay no attention
to the opinion of the masses.
It's a valuable reminder
that this is your life.
You need to take charge.
If you want success, if you
want to accomplish your goals,
if you want your life to mean something
and to have a significant impact,
you start by digging
deep to know yourself,
to find your one word,
and to set your course
in a powerful new direction.
For some people it's really
easy and they get it right away.
For others, like myself, it takes time,
analysis, and exercises to narrow it down.
If you don't do a lot of
regular self-reflection,
this will be a challenging
activity, but totally worth it.
When I found my one word,
it changed my business and my life.